animators use a variety of tools for
accurately enveloping characters however
the models produced by these tools are
often too slow for use in high
performance applications such as
training simulations and video games we
propose a technique that can learn from
a set of exported example poses and
generate a fast and accurate model for
high speed evaluation our model is also
much more expressive than linear blend
skinning currently the most common
enveloping model for real time
applications we tested our technique on
a variety of examples including muscle
bulging shoulder deformations skin
sliding and twisting we can accurately
express joints with more than one degree
of freedom like the shoulder here we
illustrate rotations along all three
degrees of freedom whereas shoulders
often cause problems for SSD our result
is almost indistinguishable from the
ground truth
our model can accurately approximate the
deformations from human scan data here
we demonstrate our technique blending
between human scan poses
nurul can express large muscle bulges as
well such as at the knee of this leg and
roughly approximate skin sliding over
bone
here we have no problems modeling the
large arms and shoulders of the
guerrilla figure while SSD causes
collapsing artifacts
you
our model even works well with this set
of artists generated extreme poses
there has been a rich body of prior work
that has tried to address the
deficiencies of SSD displacement
interpolation techniques such as post
based deformation ad corrective
displacements to an existing SSD model
but generalized poorly for cases in
which SSD cannot approximate the
rotational deformations our model
correctly captures the twisting present
in both the bar and the elbow twisting
motion is especially troublesome for SSD
requiring the displacement interpolation
techniques to capture extreme corrective
displacements because our model captures
rotations much better we complement
existing displacement interpolation
techniques by providing an alternative
to SSD previous work has also inserted
halfway joints to try to prevent
blending of large rotations because this
approach inserts these joints a PRI it
does not always generalize well for
instance consider an anatomically
inspired arm rig in which the elbow both
bends and twists we compare our
technique with that of more and gleicher
and SSD the twisting motion is enough to
impair the SSD prediction more in
glaciers technique does better but there
are still differences our result is
almost indistinguishable from the ground
truth
finally our model generalizes well to
unseen poses in this example we show our
model evaluated on a completely novel
test sequence